frauen also das ist wirklich ziemlich
schockiert cover und autoren fotos ich
habe zum beispiel hier das neue buch von
daniel kehlmann das ist nicht schön
neuerdings lassen sich die leute gerne
mit so gesenkten kopf fotografieren und
ich weiß nicht was das für ein trend ist
das ist wirklich wie sollte es
vielleicht mal präsentieren also
ungefähr so ich glaube wenn man so oder
so wenn man das cover und das autoren
will sieht dann möchte man das buch
nicht mehr lesen aber das buch ist super
was ist die wichtige cover muss schön
sein darf nicht so viel informationen
haben ich mag die haptik so dieses
geräusch dass wir nicht schön es hat
immerhin ein lesebändchen ich stehe aus
also ich muss sagen ich finde
lesebändchen wirklich nicht überflüssig
und wie findest du das autoren bild in
diesem buch so dürfen autoren bilder
seien aber nicht sogar so groß und so
das ist ganz schlimmer hätte es schlimm
stark davon abgeraten was ich immer mag
ist wenn es einen bezug gibt wie jetzt
hier
zum inhalt also das motiv dieses eis
nimmt ihr die eisverkäuferin auf ich
find ehrlich gesagt oft diese bilder aus
der kunstgeschichte bis hinab richtung
wie ich finde ein der autor sich so
stilisiert mit dem kopf nach unten wie
ja oder so es muss irgend ein foto von
mir geben wo ich das machen was hat
dieses foto im kopf dieses buch würde
ich nicht lesen wollen wie findest du
das cover unanständig obszön ja ja es
hat was auch schön ist das stimmt aber
ist nicht obszön auch wieder attraktiv
oder wenigstens irgendwie bereits am gib
mir mal dass sex buch ab also super
option make love dass männer buch wenn
man genauer hinschaut sieht man
genaueres das ist ja mitten im
geschlechtsverkehr
das wäre auch ein schöner titel für das
buch mitten im geschlechtsverkehr das
sind jetzt die bilder die ich gar nicht
zeigen darf was die leute sagen wenn du
die finger genau genau das machen wir
jetzt aber nur um zu zeigen was da wäre
wenn meine finger da nicht wenn du mir
auch hier noch so so könnte das ungefähr
zeigen vielleicht dies technisch oder
auch weil ich hier versuche die zensur
aus seine annäherungsversuche
ein schöner moment für einen schnitt